This is the cafe
I'm working
at today.
In that
series 7 secrets, the 7 secrets of language
study are
2.
When I saw it the other day, there was only Nemutsu in that series in Japanese,
so the 7 secret waters became things.
I can't go, so
today I would like to talk about
the third secret.
The
second is
my study method, but
please do what you like, in a way that you
enjoy and enjoy,
if you enjoy watching movies.  Watch a movie,
read something interesting so that you don't have to read too much,
so if you do what you like, it's
delicious in its
own
way.  One
point, when you study the language, you have to pay attention to what's going on
with this word and
this language
.
That's the second floor.
I think it's difficult for people with a little bit of difficulty, but people who
are
so-
called good at studying flying, so-called
talented people, are those who study flying, such as talent or genius.
It's not that, it's people like this, the
pronunciation or code that is the origin of
the word
.
Well then, enough so that I can get 9th place,
so what should
I do?
When you listen to, read, or talk about a lot of
things, many things become
clear.
In order to study,
you have to know it first
.
Well, if you change to that explanation of grammar, you have to get
rid of the system of words
.
You can pay attention
to that, and as you gradually become familiar with that word, you
will begin to share
more attention.
The next important thing
is that
when you study a language, you
have to take the initiative yourself,
so I made this very determination to pay attention to myself
.
You want to see what's going on, so when you read
, learn that specific phrase,
highlight it,
and that's the
point.
For that reason, I'll give you a little help
.
If you underline it and pay attention to it, the next
time you read or hear this phrase or word
in another place,
you'll be able to pay attention to it again.
That's why in
the case of our links, colors,
codes, fades, and saves
, even if it's done later, of course, it's
fine to leg, but
only the underline is just the highlights
.
That's the function of attention, that's
the middle color function, so it's going to be good.
For example
, I studied words,
not the katakana-based yachon, but how it was
actually pronounced.
By listening and pronouncing it yourself and trying to get as much of that asset out
as possible, if you do that, you'll still find
this
real hair growth door.
Of course, this includes biz 6 and intonation
.
Attention, the ability to notice what's going on in words